hey what's up guys my name is Jenna and
welcome to episode 95 of game
programming so today we're gonna take a
look at continuing our chasing mob which
is open right here and and I guess what
we're gonna do today is actually I guess
make him a little bit more complicated
but still building on this original
aspect of him basically following our
every movement now what we're gonna do
is only make him follow us if we're at a
particular distance away from him okay
so if we get too close he's gonna chase
us and if we get you know a bit further
away he's gonna stop okay and this this
tutorial is really going to be in
conjunction with the next one because
obviously right now all of our mobs move
at the same speed okay so in the next
episode of game programming episode 96
in episode 96 we're gonna talk about
actually making these mobs move at
different speeds so essentially what
we're gonna do is we're going to define
a way for us to control the speed of a
mob okay because currently they just
move at the same speed any mob we can't
actually set their speeds individually
so we'll talk about that in the next
episode but this episode again we're
gonna fundamentally lay down the code
that is that this chaser requires to
actually start chasing us if we get too
close to him okay
or her I guess I don't know okay so in
if we just map out what we need here let
me just close everything we're gonna off
we're gonna obviously in the our chase
of class and then again we're gonna need
our level class because that will help
us in determining with who gets to close
and so like that so a chaser right
fundamentally what the chase does is the
chase as a player yeah that's all it
does chase is a player now what it needs
to do to chase a player again it's only
gonna do that if if we get too close us
being the player so what the Chase is
gonna do is if we get too close it's
gonna start chasing us so he obviously
needs to know and for all intensive
purposes Chad's gonna be he okay I just
I don't have to keep repeating myself
here Shay whatever the chase is gonna
have to know right our location he's
gonna have to be like okay there are
let's just say because this is a
multiple
we'll be anyway there are 20 players on
the map yeah if either one of them gets
too close to me I'm gonna have to start
chasing him because that's what Jonah
told me to do okay so we need a method
we need a way to actually figure out if
one of these players is in our range
I guess so to do that we need to go to
the level class and actually define a
method that returns I guess an array of
entities or in this case I guess an
array of players in a certain radius
away from an entity so what we're going
to do is because we're not gonna rewrite
our code 200 times are the same thing
we're actually you want we're actually
gonna get a we're actually gonna make a
method called public list entity okay
and it's gonna be called get entities
simple as that
okay so it's gonna return a list and a
write list of entities this could be an
array there's absolutely no reason to
use an array little well it could be
there's a lot of reasons actually but
you could do this as an array if you
really want to I'm gonna do it as an
aerialist I just cuz I like them all and
dealing with them is more fun and more
flexible of course so get entities so
what we need to do is we need to specify
an entity that's actually gonna be the
entity that we get empties based on so
entity you know and I'll explain this in
more detail on that and we also need a
radius and this radius is gonna
determine basically the while I guess
the radius is obviously going to
determine the range so what we have here
let me just quickly create an array list
that says this is our result
what result so we don't so we don't get
confused so this is what's going to get
returned an array list of entities and
basically what's gonna happen here is
we're gonna cycle through all of our
entities here I less than entities dot
size you may want to for performance in
the future use something like quad trees
or another method to only get entities
that are around our location that's a
bit more advanced and will only cover
that if we really need to because of
performance considerations but
essentially what we're gonna do is for
each of these entities in size what
we're gonna do is we actually have to
have to figure out that position so
let's first of all map down this entity
that we're currently looking
so I'll call him he's already been taken
of course but the parameter so we'll
call him entity I guess as an entity an
entity entity equals entities get I so
this is a current and seeing the list
that we're looking at so what we're
gonna have to determine is the X&Y
coordinate of this entity so we can do
that obviously we made last episode in
the entity class we actually made two
methods to get X and I get Y and they
return our x and y coordinates
respectively of our entity so int x
equals entity dot get X and int y equals
entity dot get Y okay and once we've
done that we now know the location of an
entity and of course we also know the
location location of our entity here now
what we could do of course here is also
make an ax for example which will be our
ad X just in case you wanted to use that
it doesn't really matter but you know
we'll do that just so we have these
local variables so ax is our entity and
x and y are just the foreign entity that
we're looking at so what we need to do
now is figure out the distance yeah and
to figure out the distance we're gonna
have to employ some really really basic
trigonometry okay so just some just some
Pythagoras theorem essentially we just
have to basically say okay well we know
we know the distance of course on the x
axis and we can obviously figure out the
X distance by going in and saying well
quickly just so you guys know this in
case you don't again probably another
in-depth series topic but for the X we
just figure out the DX I guess the
entity there sorry that did the the
distance on the x axis by just saying
essentially X minus ax and that actually
give us the distance now the problem is
of course if X happens to be smaller
than ax so in other words if our foreign
entity is to the left of our actual
entity that we're comparing here it'll
give us a negative number which is
obviously a problem so we can just well
it's always going to be positive because
it's the distance so make sure that you
actually put methyl ABS here that will
absolute the expression actually well
the result of
expression and that'll just make it
positive essentially make sure it's
positive that we'll make sure it's
positive so in other words if that's
negative it'll make it positive okay
pretty simple stuff sure you guys
already know and we'll do the same for y
so what we have here right now is the
X&Y distance now that's great okay
that's great
but the problem is if we use this and we
just add them together what we're gonna
get is we're actually gonna get a
something Euclidean distance it's
the--it's Manhattan distance I'm pretty
sure it's been a while for me actually
since I went over this but if I open up
the track trusty paint on that here
what we'll see is that this of course
will just give us a simple if I just get
a brush here that's pretty big if our if
we right now if the chase is over here
this is the chaser and the player is
over here and we're getting the distance
here what's gonna happen is right now if
we just go ahead and say that in
distance equals DX plus dy or actually
calculating of course is this distance
that Plus that yeah and that's obviously
a bit of a problem because that is that
is the distance but that's only if we
can't move diagonally okay which we can
in our game so this is the distance that
we need to calculate so using basic
trigonometry we can work out what this
hypotenuse side is because we have the X
and we have the Y so as you know as you
should know if you well I guess went to
school ended maths x squared plus y
squared equals C squared or not or in
our case as you're right H squared so if
we rearrange this using some basic
mathematical algebra H is equal to the
square root of x squared plus y squared
okay so now that we've got that we have
X and we have Y so all we need to do is
make sure that we square them add them
together and then figure out the square
root of them so clearly that's going to
give us a decimal value of sorts so make
sure we use double and then we can round
it to an integer when required so our
distance here our real distance double
distance
this dance spell that properly is
actually equal to the square root so
math math dot square root if we refer
back to our original equation x squared
plus y squared okay so to figure out x
squared we can simply multiply the X by
itself and of course add Y squared DUI
times dy now you could use math dot
power D X for example and that would
give you um a wvt
I guess the x thing and is it okay make
sure you square of course right and that
would give us that would give us x the
DX squared but of course this is this is
just fundamentally slower than just make
basically multiplying it by itself
because that's um that's just a basic
multiplication operation whereas here
you're actually calling that method and
also I think it looks nicer because
there's too much math stuff going on if
you have math everywhere so that's the
way that that works okay really really
simple and that's it that is our
distance so now that we've figured out
the distance what we need to do is
basically say that okay well if this
distance is less than or equal to our
radius then let's add it into the list
of stuff to return off entities to
return so if distance is less than or
equal to our radius then let's actually
result dot add our entity that we're
looking at which is entity okay simple
as that and that's it
that's literally yeah that's all the
code that we need to figure out if we
are in range or not
okay else of course we'll just continue
to look it will continue by itself
obviously and that's about it so at the
end we went we just returned a list of
our entities and that when we're done
okay now this is a universal method that
will simply get all of the entities
that's it now if we want to do something
like get players we can do that as well
so public list player get players okay
and of course we need the entity to
we're referring it to so in other words
the radius that we want it to use here
so in other words because we're because
the way that we're getting these players
is actually by um by figuring out if
they're within a radius
of a particular entity which we near
specified calls the entity and the
radius that we want to compare to and
all we need to do here is simply compile
a list of players or essentially we
could compile a list of entities here
and it will me to actually so this is
these are our entities and we'll just
simply get entities that are within a
and our radius
okay so we're referring back to this
method that we just created and then
we'll have to loop through these things
once again entities dot size I plus plus
and we'll will loop through these and
we'll say that if essentially entities
yeah entities get I is actually an
instance of a player will actually add
it into our new array list which has to
be an array list here of players called
players or we'll just call results since
that's the one we returning equals new
ArrayList player and of course will
simply result dot add player or rather
result of add and T's get my okay and of
course we'll need to cast this to a plan
which of course it will always that will
never give us a class cast exception
because we're actually checking to see
if it is an instance on the player okay
and that's it let's just remove this
stuff here and make it one big line
because that's how I roll and I think
that's pretty much it
okay we'll add it if not we'll do keep
looking okay and then of course we need
to return our result right so that's
great okay let's test out these methods
now so if we go to player now we go to
update here this isn't the player class
obviously another choice of class we can
just print out here I should really make
a way to print out to the screen because
what we're doing here the word is
printing into the console and I have to
actually move my screen recorder
essentially one while I'm editing the
video to show you guys the output so I
will um probably maybe lit up the
episode after before maybe maybe before
we did the AI algorithm since printing
stuff to the screen will be useful for
that so I can explain it better before
we do the SSI chakra them ah probably
just go
making a method to print text to the
screen we haven't covered that yet okay
so system.out.print line
well first of all we'll get all the
entities around here yeah so we'll make
a new ArrayList called a or a s whatever
entities equals level dot get entities
sorry I I just actually installed
Windows so I don't know why but uhm
Eclipse isn't giving me any suggestions
because I don't think I've installed a
component that I should have so what was
it called get entities and we level okay
so we need be at the entity that we're
comparing from which is this entity and
the radius we'll just say our 50 that's
probably too far maybe 20 okay so make
sure we import everything here next make
sure it's from util and the entities
here of course all right cool so now
that we've done that we can just
basically for each of these eyes less
than oh look you're probably just to a
4h for this actually so entity a yes
all right so for each of these entities
I usually don't like using 4h lists
because they can cause concurrency
issues but this is this should be
absolutely fine because we're not
referencing this anywhere else but I
would avoid them honestly and also that
they don't give you the I variable that
I like to play around with if you do a
for loop if you do like a normal full
loop of course you do get this I
variable that you can use to get indexes
of things and actually measure other
things that's that's a shame as well but
doesn't matter so yes dot what's a
what's a good one I guess we could just
um we could print the amount yeah in
fact we don't even need this then we'll
keep it if now but we'll just we'll
print the size of this and we'll also
print the name so simply a okay so if we
launch this so there's zero entities
around us and suddenly there's five
oh there's five chaser mom's oh we made
five didn't we uh-huh
yeah we did okay let's go back into it
well that proves that it works right if
we go back into spawn level here we can
see we add five chaser mobs let's not do
that okay so what I'll do now is I'll
kind of bring this down here so you guys
can see what's going on and you can see
that over here we're getting one and
it's just a tracer you can see right
here and that's the memory address not
important but it's a chaser okay and if
we go closer we if we go pretty close to
this one let's see if we go pretty close
to a dummy and this is very close by the
way that's why it's hard to kind of
achieve you can see we get to over here
and it's printing both let's widen this
radius it's incredibly small I didn't
think it would be that small to be
honest if we go back into our player and
we go to the radius let's just buff that
up to about eighty I don't know fiftieth
I was thinking fifty that we'll see I
will see how far that is okay yeah
that's about the distance so we got one
over here I wish that chase if we go
closer this one you can see we've got
the dummy as well yeah go closer this
dummy can we get both of them in there
maybe yep - no okay we can definitely
add both of these in yep three see and
basically what we're getting here is
we're actually getting um the entities
there are there are around us and that's
of course very very useful so that's how
that works now let's make the chase
let's actually do what we set out to do
and make the chaser follow the player
essentially so let's get rid of all this
code and by poor the player of course
main for the player if he gets close
enough so what we'll do over here is
every um as we move here yeah instead of
just getting the client player and doing
this stuff we'll basically need to get a
list of entities or actually players of
course so players equals level get
players this and a radius of around 40
I'd say okay so now that we've done this
in fact I'll make it 50 now that we've
done this all we need to do we say that
if
Oh or essentially instead of player
being one of these right because there's
only one player right now anyway instead
of getting the client player here we'll
simply get players right dot get I and
that's one of these I also get by what
I'm telling they get zero okay
now of course this isn't always true
because sometimes players is will be 0
this one because of course our our
chaser doesn't always have to be in
range of a player so we'll simply make
sure that he only follows someone if
players oops
yeah if players dot size is actually
greater than zero okay so if the players
besides greater than zero let's do this
stuff okay simple as that
sorry let's test that out so he's not
following us now if we just wait here
for a minute we'll see that he's not
coming okay and there's a bunch of these
dummy wallets but if we get close enough
here and I'll try and make sure that
he's where's that chaser he's read see
he's not following us now but if we get
too close okay we got close nothing
happened that was anticlimactic right
there so let's see what on earth went
wrong here so we're getting players it's
in the range of here let's make sure
that players is actually returning
something this is the choice of
programming so let's return players of
size here so that's 0 its 0 and it's
still zero okay so it's like anything
players something must be wrong without
get players method so this clearly works
so this entity thing so of course the
reason this isn't working of course is
because I'm an idiot first of all but
also because armed players is obviously
in a separate array list from entities
and because of that it's not checking
that so get players it shouldn't
actually be any any of this get players
should should actually be the same
method but for our players this makes
things a little more complicated kind of
got that so what we need to do is I'm
honestly considering just adding players
into the main array list here that would
make things much more simple hmm
we're not gonna do that though okay so
we don't need get on tears anymore okay
my bad I thought that I thought that the
player was in the entities ArrayList
it's not so make sure that instead what
we do is we actually check players dot
size and we'll do the same thing here
we'll just copy and paste this code over
here into right over here okay
and we'll get player P will be players
dot get high and instead of this we'll
use on we'll discuss my play here
instead eventually we will of course
replace that with player here so and
instead of these guys will copy and
paste them again here and write out oh
yeah that's fine so and that's that
stays as it is we've got a last stop
down which is good so result on add
player all right and we don't need this
anymore and that's that's it
we'll just return result so they're
essentially the same with their checking
different write lists probably not a
good design but the thing is is for
players and players will be I think
players will essentially be the only
unique entities of course disregarding
stuff like projectiles and particles I
may put these into one or a list called
effects or something because that's what
they are
well projectiles not really with
particles yes players do deserve their
own ray list though I'm pretty sure just
because I'm of course they are they are
quite a unique entity because they're
controlled by humans anyway now that
I've justified myself let's see if this
one works so if we launch we've got zero
here and if we get close enough here
what we should see is one and the guy
should start chasing us here he is our
red clown here here he is and let's see
if we get close enough does he start
tracing us yep okay there he goes you
can see this changes to one okay so
that's how that works
I'll demonstrate it one more time in
case you guys didn't catch that and
actually before I do that I will stop
printing let's go back to chaser and
stop printing players up sighs yeah
go down all the way here he is and there
we go start chasing us as we get close
okay so that is episode 95 game
programming next time we'll talk we'll
talk a look at giving entities different
speeds so that our chairs for example
move slower than us so that we have a
chance to outrun us
otherwise he will just follow us
indefinitely and then after that we'll
probably take a look at oh well we'll
take a look at at making this pay I a
bit more complicated but also after that
you know before the eyes tell such a
growth and we'll definitely implement
text and stuff like that
text run ring to the screen which will
be relatively simple but necessary so I
hope you guys enjoyed this episode again
programming if you did please the like
button you know the deal 200 likes one
video per day 300 likes two videos per
day and I'll see you guys next time
goodbye
you